we are continuing to hear from some key
political figures who knew reed
professionally as well as personally
madison kimbrough continues our team
coverage from harry reid international
airport with what was said
and here we are at an airport named
after the political trailblazer the name
change just happened a couple weeks ago
you can see it's already there's a lot
of signage up and tonight we hear from
several of his political colleagues on
the impact he made on their lives and
our state there's no way even more
important for nevada than what he's done
the passing of former senator harry reid
has his colleagues coming together to
say a few words about a man they
describe as a mentor and a caring
individual clark county commissioner
tick sagebloom has been a huge advocate
for the recent name change to harry reid
international airport a moment he is
proud reid was able to see i've been
talking about this bill for four years
to try to have it happen
so the fact that it just finally came to
fruition of course we voted on several
months ago but actually have this
official ceremony two weeks before he
died was very important for me reid was
the longest serving senator in nevada
history when he retired in 2017. he was
in public office before myself
and provided some guidance and
assistance he's always thoughtful former
nevada first lady don gibbons recalls
the ease of their friendship and how he
always was there for her even during the
toughest of times any time i had a
problem
i just texted him he just was kind of
fatherly to me and
and uh you know it meant something to me
i lost my father um from suicide when i
was 16. he lost his father when he was
about 30 to suicide more than just a
political figure the memory of the work
he put in for the silver state will
never be forgotten we will carry on his
legacy
senator reid was a hard worker he was a
fighter he was a true champion
for
every community every individual
and harry reid is survived by his wife
and his five children reporting live
inside of harry reid international
airport madison kimbrough live local now